Je dois parler à César alors
que l'aube commence, le sentiment est que c'est l'
aube d'une nouvelle espèce que ce sont
des singes intelligents qui ont hérité de la
terre,
ce qui s'est passé entre Rhys et
notre film, c'est que Wetty
a fait un bond en avant, ce
film est en fait  à bien des égards plus
difficile que le premier film en termes
de portée son échelle évidemment
quelque chose qui allait être énorme pour le
succès de ce film parce que le
dernier film de Sun nous avions des arènes assez grandes mais
cette fois presque tout était à l'extérieur
ça ne l'a jamais été  fait comme ça avant de
décider d'utiliser des caméras 3D et vraiment
ce que nous voulions faire était de prendre cette
technologie qui s'est perfectionnée et de l'
appliquer dans des décors extérieurs encore plus
que nous ne l'avons fait à la hausse, nous travaillons pour
la plupart en moins
la capture de mouvement dans un environnement contrôlé fonctionne car
elle peut voir ce que font les acteurs et
lorsque vous filmez dans une forêt pleine d'
arbres, cela rend les choses très délicates, nous avons donc
eu deux sommeils spécialement arrangés  ns de
caméras à chaque fois que nous changeons d'emplacement
juste pour essayer de pouvoir
obtenir avec précision les performances des acteurs
et les caméras sans fil
fonctionnaient très bien dans ce type d'environnement
car nous n'avions pas à nous soucier de la
pose et de l'entretien des câbles qu'il
nous a donné  beaucoup de liberté, ils utilisent
des caméras de capture de mouvement, des
marqueurs de suivi et des caméras témoins pour capturer
tous les détails des
performances des acteurs, puis ils suivent
ce détail dans ces
huit modèles photoréalistes, l'autre chose bien que cela ait
été d'une grande aide sur  ce film était
les véritables brins de marqueurs corporels actifs
et vous pouviez donc attacher cela aux
artistes que vous connaissez et ils pouvaient rouler,
ils pouvaient se battre, ils pouvaient faire
tout ce qu'ils devaient
faire en tant que singes,
alors vraiment beaucoup vient juste  dans
le logiciel que nous avons écrit pour aider à
traduire cela après avoir acquis toutes
les informations pour vraiment
comprendre plus précisément ce que font les
acteurs  ing et être en mesure de voir que la
simulation des cheveux, la simulation de la peau, la simulation de
l'humidité, tout ce
qu'ils font en termes de corps réels des singes
est tellement plus réaliste l'une
des grandes choses que nous avons
introduites dans le pipeline qui n'était
que  à peine vu vous savez dans le dernier
film était tout cet élément de fourrure humide
nous voyons les singes quand ils sont secs nous les
voyons quand ils sont humides nous les voyons quand
ils sont un peu trempés ont envoyé un
système incroyablement compliqué et c'est
l'incroyable magie de ce qu'il
fait, c'est de trouver la manière dont ils
peuvent prendre les rôles des acteurs et les
rôles des singes et les fusionner de
telle sorte que cette émotion vienne en
voyant les résultats est incroyablement
excitant
[Musique]